hi und herzlich willkommen hier im
Großen Sendesaal des Westdeutschen
Rundfunks wir sind hier weil wir was
Großes anzukündigen haben bei kriegsum
gibt es was neues und zwar das kleinste
Konzert der Welt der erste Gast Anna
Depenbusch das sind übrigens die
einzigen sechs Tickets die könnt ihr
gewinnen an der Depenbusch hat ein
sensationelles neues Album rausgebracht
die Mathematik der Busch die könnt ihr
gewinnen wenn ihr auf anklicks zum
gmail.com Mails wie viele Titel auf
ihrem neuen Album sind und wo das ganze
stattfindet eins wissen wir in Hamburg
aber wo da noch nicht denn ihr könnt
euch bewerben mit Fotos von eurem
Jugendzimmer Wohnzimmer Partykeller egal
was das könnt ihr posten an die Pinnwand
der Krieg zum Fanpage auf
facebook.com/xum und dann gucken wir mal
wo es am besten passt und das ganze
könnt ihr natürlich auch sehen nicht nur
die sechs alle auf unseren neuen Kanal
klickst du music abonniert ihn jetzt
dann verpasst er nicht jetzt hier drauf
gepackt und dann ist erst der Anfang
verpasst ihr keins der kleinsten
Konzerte der Welt